I'm going to tell you a story it's a
story of Woe it's a story of dishonesty
and trickery it's a story of nearlys
it's the story of the Stargate Revival
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so in the story I am going to tell you
everything the entire thing from SGU
getting canceled right up to what we
know today this is only part one of the
series so keep an eye open for the rest
in 2011 Stargate SGU much to the
annoyance and anger of the fans got
canceled now the Sci-Fi Network knew
that this was a controversial decision
and they had actually a fair bit of
respect for the Stargate franchise they
actually wrote a letter to gateworld
Craig Engler who was the co-executive in
charge of the Sci-Fi Network wrote an
open letter kind of apologizing to the
fans now he said that we had such
confidence in Stargate Universe after
the success of Stargate SG-1 and
Stargate Atlantis that we agreed two
seasons now to me that actually showed a
real confidence is in Brad Wright and
the rest of the team that they gave them
this deal for two seasons now that just
doesn't happen anymore if you think
about Star Trek we don't know what is
happening beyond what is currently being
filmed they just don't announce anything
like this anymore series just don't get
that confidence anymore in Craig
Angler's explanation of why it was
canceled he talked about how they put in
certain Milestones certain expectations
for the series and he just basically
said those expectations were never met
but what expectations is he talking
about viewing figures sadly the viewing
figures for SGU were simply lower than
Stargate Atlantis and Stargate sg1 it
never quite captured the imagination of
the fans but why was that well it was a
very experimental change in tone and
style for the Stargate franchise they
they did away with a lot of the humor
and the cheekiness from Stargate sg1 and
Atlantis they completely changed the
Cinematic style of the show going for a
much darker feel and some fans loved it
I mean we talk about SGU on this channel
a lot and the videos we do talking about
Stargate SGU always do astonishingly
well
they do well because people love the
Sears and they want a continuation they
want an answer to the series
but the people that don't like it well
they comment on those videos as well and
to be honest in the UK we call it a bit
of a Marmite TV show you either love it
or hate it and some people really
disliked it for me I honestly found it a
little boring I found it quite difficult
to watch but I have rewatched it since
and actually I appreciated a lot more
the second time around and I will say as
well 100 it was getting better it was
getting far more exciting by the end of
the series and I actually do wish and
really am annoyed that we never got a
third series because I think if it got a
third series we'd have got at least five
and that would have been really
brilliant because we'd have got all
those answers that we never got so it
was canceled because of the ratings
not entirely Stargate Universe was also
incredibly expensive it was actually the
most expensive out of the three series
to produce
now partly that was because of the
change in style as I say cinematically
the show was much bigger it was much
grander
um it had more detailed effects so from
that point of views are more expensive
as well but also it had actors in it
like Robert Carlisle that were expensive
contracts these guys were on decent
money
but their initial contract would have
been for two seasons if it had carried
on those contracts would have had to
have been reworked and renegotiated so
they would have become even more
expensive and there was also an issue
because the Canadian dollar when
Stargate started was actually far weaker
than the US dollar it was loads cheaper
to produce TV series in Canada and
that's why the TV show was produced in
Vancouver
but by the end of SGU the Canadian
dollar was a lot stronger so all of a
sudden it was becoming more expensive to
produce the show just basically because
of the exchange rate
it was just becoming way too expensive
to produce the show
so
it was just inevitable it was going to
get canceled
so in 2011 we saw the end of Stargate
we have seen nothing on our screen since
and even though we have kept up the
campaign and here on this channel we
have shouted as loudly as we can we want
Stargate back we still have no news
about a reboot but was that always the
case or did we become very close to a
reboot well in 2015 we did but it was
the reboot nobody wanted and nobody
asked for and in fact I'm really glad
never got made but in 2015 Roland
Emerick and Dean Devlin did announce
that a project to do Stargate 2 the
sequel was actually greenlit by MGM now
it very quickly and very quietly got on
greenlit and canceled but for a short
period of time there was development
work being done on a Stargate sequel now
this would have been a direct sequel to
the 1994 movie starring James Spader and
Kurt Russell and apparently James Spader
and Kurt Russell had been approached and
were willing to return to the series now
the plan was to make the trilogy of
movies that Roland Emrick and Dean
Devlin always envisaged and that was
going to ignore what had happened in the
television series now according to
Amanda Tapping who did an interview
around this time she talked about what
she thought about that movie and one of
the things she said was Dean Devlin and
Roland Emerick they never really like
disliked the TV show but it wasn't what
they had envisaged for it so even though
they thought the TV show was okay it was
not what they wanted to do with the
Stargate franchise
so they saw this as an opportunity to
reset it now rolandemic has talked about
this since he has talked about why he
thinks the project was canceled
and basically he has said the TV
audience is more important and when
talking about whether he thinks that
project could happen now and whether a
movie for Stargate would happen he said
that yes if a Stargate movie happens I
would be involved because I'm
contractually obliged to be but he
doesn't think he would get to make his
vision for Stargate anymore because the
TV audience is all Amazon cares about
thank Christ Dean Devlin and Roland
Emerich wanted to erase Stargate sg1 SG
Atlantis and SG Universe he wanted to
pretend like it had never happened
but he didn't get his chance and all I
can say is
thank you
I wouldn't have minded seeing James
Spader and Kurt Russell return but
the time has passed Stargate is about
Richard Dean Anderson's version of Jack
O'Neill now Michael Shanks is Daniel
Jackson Christopher judges teal can
Amanda tappings Samantha Carter
those are the stars we want to see
return
and those are the stars we hope to see
return at some point in the future
so in the next video in this series I'm
going to be talking about mgm's plans to
reboot the franchise and the pandemic
that stopped it and then everything that
happened during the sale of MGM to
Amazon their bat is where we start to
get some little twists and turns to this
story please go against the comments
tell me exactly what you think about
everything that's happened up till now
and I'd love to know how confident are
you and a scale of one to ten one being
none 10 being it's definitely happening
that Stargate will return just out of
Interest let us know what you're
thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
Sidetrack and for a small fee you can
join us there I put most of our videos
on there before YouTube
so you can see them first and without
the adverts as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you